also ich habe immer sage ich sagt ok es
gibt in youtube deutschland viele
youtube millionäre
also leute die mit youtube millionen
verdient haben wir alle für immer wieder
fragen von zuschauern um ihr doch klar
wurde dass zuschauer einfach überhaupt
keine idee davon hat wie das so ist bei
youtube - über geld verdient wird kommen
viele fragen wie diese leicht verdientes
geld obwohl es überhaupt nichts zu tun
hat oder abos berlin
obwohl doch überhaupt nichts zu tun hat
deswegen dieses video um alle menschen
aufzuklären
ich habe gebeten die fragen stellen über
dinge die euch noch unklar sind die wir
beantworten man wird sich einige feucht
klären sofort druck bedeutet der was
kann also der kanal von rechts zusammen
mit unitymedia kurz vor 2008 entsteht
bei 19.600 richtig damit ihr euch noch
die kranich 1000 voll machen können und
welche gehalte deswegen gegen deren auch
experte länger beschreibung und lachte
einfach ein abo der verletzungspause
vorher machen sich wer super leute also
jeder klopft aber voll machen hier im
video gerne von alien ist über
eigentlich ihre einnahmen versteuern
weil es mein youtuber denke ich eher
nicht so ein anerkannter biochemiker
müssen ihre einnahmen versteuern und das
wird richtig heftig ergebnis von oder
ganze menge geld die man dann so eine
junge person am steuer zahlen muss schon
jetzt sich auf jeden fall aber leute
hinter uns es gibt einige youtuber die
wm truck die länder könnte man auch mit
dem geld von youtube leben wenn nicht
verläuft unterschiedlich die größten in
deutschland haben wahrscheinlich schon
ausgesorgt hat kann man glaube ich zu
sagen die ich für meinen teil könnte von
dem was jetzt vielleicht verdient aber
nichts dran geteilt hat vielleicht noch
zwei jahre leben maximal sind nichts
cloud gebe auf jeden fall gewiss nicht
unverändert über immer in reichweite
gewinnen und plötzlich sehen dass sie
damit geld machen können machen wir das
zu machen beispiel okay wenn ihr mit
freunden unterwegs sein gibt es gewisse
dinge ihr vorliegenden machen könnten
gewisse die energiepolitik nicht machen
können weil die euch
strafen in denen ihr euch verachtenden
ignorieren beim liegt man vielleicht
nicht mehr einladen benedikt wolfers
nicht beleidigt ist die
wahrscheinlichkeit hoch dass sie beim
nächsten mal nicht mehr einladen
dementsprechend neben die rücksicht auf
das was sie wollen und respektiert die
und saß häufig gesehen wäre jetzt aber
haben können können wir bei der angriff
ist wenn jetzt aber auch einmal ganz
viel geld und ganz viel einfluss habe
glaube ich kann man sich mehr erlauben
weil andere leute einem er durchgemacht
haben bin ich fest überzeugt größer oder
für leute die mehr geld und mehr
einfluss fahren gerne diesen spielraum
ausnutzt und dann wirklich auch mehr
erlauben weil sie sich eben mehr
erlauben können also noch mal das was
ich glaube ich das geld in einen fluss
menschen kaputt macht aber es wird sehr
wohl dass du dich weniger zurückhaltend
viel mehr von ihrem wahren oder
ungefiltert nicht zeigen eine fragliche
abonnenten haben damit einem leben ohne
anderen job gern tieren kann die
behandelt das so es kommt überhaupt
nicht auf die abonnenten also das muss
die koffer blick vergessen abonnenten
sind egal und likes sind egal für die
einnahmen mit kommt nur auf die klicks
auf die werbung die vor den videos
gescheitet würde die zuschauer nicht an
den dafür bekommt man das youtube geld
du ein ganz ganz ganz großen maßstab
wenn man regelmäßig hoch leder so
glücklich wenn sich gleich atheist und
ansonsten verlaufe die merchandise
parlament wird kann vielleicht so aus
dem 200.000 abonnenten davon leben aber
das ist eine ganz ganz große zahl wie
viel geld man zum leben braucht brauchen
wir den labor ab ich brauche meine
spiele bis braucht man sich auf einige
flaschen für 1000 euro im glück wenn man
alles nicht brauchen normale reaktion
ist aber normales leben als single
die personen sind 200 bis 250 tausend
abonnenten denken also wenn man davon
leben kann
wenig konkret wie zum beispiel nur
einmal pro woche braucht man deutlich
mehr reichweite und das heißt mehr
abonnenten um an diesen punkt zu kommen
wohl wirklich davon leben kann erreicht
betont vor - und hört bei herbert wollte
mir eure woche youtube zu groß obwohl
der schon genug geld besitzen tust du
dich die sache ist man gewöhnt sich an
alles leute wenn ich einen tipp im leben
geben kann glaubt mir beim gewöhnlichen
alles gute und schlechte derzeit zum
beispiel ganz einfach mal eines tages
wieder anfängt zu laufen
fünf junge mann macht dich fertig ist
und schrecklichste macht nochmal nochmal
nochmal noch machen nochmal und beim
zehnten mal hat sich dann der körper
quasi dahin gebildet noch am meisten für
anstrengend aber sie sind auch für den
gesagt wirklich leute ausgeholt und ich
denke das auto für mich drei wochen und
dann ist es gewohnheit und dann denkt
man sich
ich brauchte nicht originale und
deswegen wird man sich auch an viel viel
geld wenn man viel geld gewöhnt hat will
man noch mehr geld und noch mehr geld
und noch mehr geld maria nur mary fragt
kann man ja große youtuber wieder mit
leben fährt ihr know-how tt.com
da will ich sagen ja jetzt gerade geht
mir relativ gut muss ich da recht
zufrieden glücklich dass ich das nicht
mehr kann brückler anbieten kann
vielleicht möchte aber ich sag mal so
youtube eine million or 1 8 millionen
die regeln klar dass es da also ich kann
immer sage ich danke
es gibt in youtube deutschland viele
youtube millionäre
also leute die mit youtube millionen
verdient haben aber glücklich mit
kleinen gestiftete 1 beck die
erfolgreichen pc oder zum deutschland
wie möglich ans parlament gemacht und
dann gibt es zwischen ganz viele die
einmal über die 10.000 rad gekommen sind
wurde gerade davon leben können bei
80.000 abonnenten oder irgendwo in der
mitte stehen dazwischen ist bei knappen
vertrauen da findest du bist super
sicher immerhin hat man nichts richtiges
gelernt könnte ja wenn die roboter sagt
vollkommen recht der beruflich überhaupt
alles andere als sicher und kann sagen
ich keinen rat gegen den fv endlich
macht aber weniger tauglich machen würde
ohne irgendeinen abschluss daheim oder
oder irgendeine andere möglichkeit haben
zu arbeiten
da dürfe obwohl vorgänger franken leute
leute weinen praktiker luxuswagen
stichkanal bei den leuten richtig
scheiße
das macht ihr da habt ihr auch ein pferd
gewählt und das pferd ist unter euren
beiträgen brauchen mehr anlauf in die
villinger in der bürger rechnung bezahlt
oder treten lebenszeit gewohnt deutlich
höher
ich weiß natürlich zehn jahren da ist
richtig scheiße der zehn mal mit studio
geht man mit laser etwa fragt wie viel
geld verdient weil eigentlich wirklich
im monat möchte ich einfach keine genaue
zahl sagen möchte danach kaka ersetzt
auch einfach sogleich meiner
privatsphäre ich sagte höchstens meinen
engsten freunden was die gespräche
praktisch aber wie gesagt momentan kann
ich relativ unter problem ich kann mir
auszuweiten nicht ergreifen ich kann mir
klamotte leiten könnte ich mich auch mit
derivaten also momentan ist wirklich zu
vergleich mit dem sehr guten vollzeitjob
aber daneben auch die ich will ganz ohne
deutsche im feld paar millionen im jahr
verdienen und sich über die weiter unten
in der nahrungskette stehen die halter
irgendwie im jahr fünf euro für 700.000
euro mehr freiheit die viel geld bekommt
man so für produktplatzierungen klasse
seiner ex-band sagte
viele produkte sind wenn youtube produkt
an das ihrem video vorstellen das kann
der erste eines kann
damenbinden sei auf die nase fällt das
geld für solche verlag rechnung bekommen
von 500 euro an und geht hoch bis 100000
5 video wenn nicht sogar mehr also die
top youtuber in deutschland verdienen
solche beträge für ein video arbeitet
sie können eine handaufzucht von diesem
video langer zeit schon mega light es
gibt so viele weitere fragen beantworten
können sie alleine zu den mégane viele
weitere freilich gerne beantworten würde
wenn ihr vom 2 so haben wir richtig was
braucht es in die kommentare und das
entsprechende aktion bekommt ihr
natürlich vorgeschlagen das video hier
unten können wir hier oben